this great big story was made possible
by wells fargo established 1852
re-established 2018.
this
is myron
hi
myron is an athlete i played a little
football in college and
i was a rhodes scholar and
i played for the nfl
and
i have a master's degree in medical
anthropology and
and i'm a neurosurgeon sheesh
my first
dream was to play professional football
there's no question
i was very active as a young man and i
knew that i was pretty good at it when i
got to the fifth grade that's when i
knew i wanted to pursue my second dream
i read a book called gifted hands by ben
carson who looked like me he was black
who came from a similar socio-economic
background as me you know we didn't have
much money when we left the bahamas and
came to america and the more i read
about it the more i knew that once i was
done playing football neurosurgery was
going to be the pathway in the second
chapter of my life
i was the number one rated high school
player in the country for football
recruited by everyone 83 scholarship
offers i always felt that football fed
academics academics fed football
myron spent his college years playing
football and shadowing doctors
he graduated in two and a half years and
was expected to be a first or second
round draft pick in the nfl with a
multi-million dollar contract but he
also had a chance to study at oxford as
a rhodes scholar
i ended up deciding to go to oxford and
saying no to the nfl i spent a year and
a half over there came back to the
united states went into the draft and
got drafted in the sixth round instead
of the second or first made seventy
thousand dollars instead of six million
played for three years got out healthy
felt good about my time there frankly
made enough money to pay for medical
school i didn't have any lasting
concussions and my hands were okay where
i was able to do surgery in the
operating room and so i left on my own
volition started medical school and here
i am now
since head injuries are common on the
football field myron works to impress
the importance of avoiding concussions
on young players
but for myron his days of tackling are
behind him
football was great for that season of my
life but now this is it this is the
pinnacle this is this is where i belong
and i've told my parents several times
over and over again they asked me myer
how do you feel what you're doing now
how do you feel i said mommy and daddy i
feel like this is where i belong so did
you say you played a sport before yes
[Music]
[Music]
you